the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the title of grand master highly coveted
and sought after since the beginning of
the game
welcome to the third st louis norm
congress
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2022 saint louis norm congress
it's an exciting day here today at the
congress my name of course is caleb
denby and we are going to be going over
uh some of the games today a lot of
games still in action a lot has also
already been determined so exciting
stuff
uh first let's talk about what a norm
congress is you know what what is what
is a norm why is everybody here
uh so of course a norm is a uh
requirement to get chess titles so right
now in this tournament we have players
competing for the international master
and grand master norms to get those
titles
so in general a player must score
quantifiably well in a tournament where
at least three other players already
hold the title being sought so gm norm
section we've got three gm's i am norm
section we've got three ims the average
rating of all the players must be above
a minimum threshold and at least four
national federations must be represented
uh or even more if the fields are larger
beyond that of course you also have to
do well in the tournament so they have
to uh get to a certain performance
rating in order to achieve a norm
um as of this morning let's check out
where the fields stood as far as
standings in the grand master section
after seven rounds vlad beluse was in
the lead by a full
point and we will see that uh perhaps
he's ahead by even more after today of
course balaji doug potti was also having
a reasonably good events uh one in round
seven to bring him to five uh points
chris repka also is at 4.5 points david
brodsky on four josiah also on 4 and the
rest of the field trails not too far
behind
then over in the international master
section it is the story of josh poshma
and matias merrick
they were tied for the lead with five
and a half points each aaron grabinski
uh was having a great tournament as well
but unfortunately lost in round seven
jennifer you close behind with four
points the game and ezra both on three
and a half and then you see the rest of
the field trailing uh not too far behind
um all right why don't we check out what
the schedule is for this event of course
we do not have too many more rounds left
to go uh tomorrow is the ninth and final
round and then if we do have ties for
first place there will be a playoff
going on at 4 p.m
uh be sure to join us on both twitch and
youtube we're going out live here and
without further ado why don't we get
into uh what's going on today in round
eight uh we should have some pretty
interesting pairings and there you do
see it vladimir blues defeats josiah
stearman and that is actually going to
secure first place for him in the grand
master section we also have david
brodsky um
winning his game against joshua ruiz we
have chris
with the draw against bellagi dagupati
which is part of what secures vlad
beluse's victory
and then we have two games remaining in
progress between evan park and ivan
skeetko and victor modvietion against
kosher kabutsuki
um and why don't we take a look at vlad
beluse's game and see how he won the
tournament
um
so yeah can i ask you to go check in
with with ben um okay so vlad loose had
the black pieces here up against josiah
stearman went e4 c5 knight f3 knight c6
d4 c takes d4 knight takes d4 so we had
an open sicilian uh classical open
sicilian and then the richter rouser
look at this all right so bishop d7 to
start with which is one of the normal
moves i guess e6 is slightly more common
so we continue on and then an early f4
by white okay so this is making for an
interesting game so rook c8 we see a6
and i think we might be
transposing to to some very strange
lines okay uh queen d4 we get e6 queen
side castles
black castles king side and then you're
gonna get the classic sicilian uh types
of attacks so black is gonna be uh
challenging white down the c file white
pushing on the king's side both players
aiming to checkmate
and looks like white picks up this rook
on
f8 okay really complex tactics here
already and then white takes on f3
getting the material back and then i
think i actually peeked on this game
after bishop takes d1 and i was quite
surprised by this move ft c6 but i think
this move was was actually very tricky
um if black attempts to save the bishop
i believe i i think rook f7 would be the
idea and i'm not so sure that black
would have had a good response here
of course if you capture
queen f2 is going to regain the peace
and if you don't capture then you're
going to have pretty serious issues with
things like e7 and why am i talking
about this game because we have the man
himself uh welcome to the show vlad uh
congratulations on your tournament
thank you
yes about uh about this game yeah f5 was
a huge blunder
well
yeah it's uh yeah so this move f5
yeah and uh my opponent told me that he
didn't prepare rouser and actually like
uh yeah i was like this all these
tournaments i'm playing i'm trying to
play openings that i never played
because every time uh these guys they're
super strong they're they're preparing
against me and i get very bad positions
but here like i got like a yeah
f5 yeah 94 and it looks like it's
already over but uh he he he was
defending uh very well yes so some kind
of complicated desperado tactics here
yeah and okay he can take uh back let's
say uh
bishop is seven okay like like let's say
94 yeah yeah i just take yeah and and
yeah now if e7 you take an f3
maybe on c2
oh yeah i'm sorry
but yeah before bishop g5 and like uh i
always tell my students
opposite color bishop is uh is in your
favor
when you are talking and i'm i'm the one
who attacking and i have extra point
here so i was kind of okay i'm i'm gonna
at least i um i'm not worth here yeah
certainly pleasant yeah and so i guess
what he did might be the most critical
then yes i think so so b7 knight c3 of
course bishop freight and also important
that uh checkmate on g7 i cannot take
immediately on f3 right yeah so i have
to take with the rook okay and right now
yeah everything is hanging like he
cannot take bishop c6 because knight e2
and rook on d1 is hanging uh
yeah yeah so
lots of problems to try to solve yeah
but he he i i thought that he's gonna
resign like uh very soon but he was
defending very well like
so
i was mentioning him up with this
interesting idea to go rook f1 yeah and
then after bishop d1 take on e6 bishop
d1 maybe e5 was easier i don't know yeah
it looks like that's what the the
computer is saying so this this fe 6
idea was this a surprise to you um not
really but actually this uh this
computer it's not good because
second second round i i calculated
brilliant combination actually it worked
and then i checked leeches and
they like said that
[Music]
it's not very correct but i checked with
my engine and it was exactly what i was
calculating but yeah rukufan well bishop
d1 uh yeah i i saw after xc6 uh but uh
yeah i saw it uh yeah ftx is six yes
uh
i know first of all i wanted to play
bishop too but i forgot uh you before i
join you you mentioned
yes i was looking at this line
i think it's not very precise uh if you
if you want if you want to trade you
have to take e-tex f7 ah so i thought
against ef you might just have king h8
uh cleaning the six queen d6 looks
problematic actually yeah
so maybe you have to give
uh yeah maybe you have to give a check
first no well then you just take yeah
okay so so and after rook f7 the problem
is uh i can play queen g5 and i don't
know like you have to move your king
somewhere right and
i'm playing right now queen b5
25 check so my bishop is not hanging
anymore and then i just take on f7 yeah
okay makes sense yeah so so ef was was
the problem yeah ef and i forgot like i
was calculating kind of and i forgot
that after rook f7 rook f7 king f7
uh queen of two is where i just i just
missed this chat yeah and you know uh
this uh
uh
uh
queen quincean game kind of tricky so of
course you have to calculate millions of
checks so and uh again i'm telling my
students be lazy in a good way during
your game so don't calculate unless you
need to yes yes exactly exactly so and
uh yeah i played the i'm not sure
because you should so you came up with
this move which i mean it seems good
enough right um so white does still go
for this ef7 idea yes um so if kinghead
i guess this is still the problem yes
exactly um so you you captured and then
after queen to c4 yeah and here i kind
of hallucinated again like okay like i'm
fine like i saw everything but i like
my uh hallucination was about that i
have i'm having two extra puns instead
of one but i don't know
like a simple math like i couldn't uh i
couldn't
of course
every pawn on the board is pretty weak
though right yeah i mean it should be
winning i think rook and game but yeah
of course the trick is is queen c8 here
so uh queen back to c7 to defense yeah
and then no matter which piece you you
take black can just recapture so he goes
for the rook end game
yeah i mean it's the best the best
option for him yeah i guess you can't
ever get a queen end game from this
position like he you know queen d5 the
bishop it's also tricky kind of queen e6
queen of six
okay i have bishop a4 ah yeah defending
the yeah uh all the squares yeah so
bishop a4 was
kind of uh yeah so in in the rook end
game though um
yeah my impression was just that the
white white can't hold everything and
he's down upon as well i was thinking
that okay like i i think i missed
something but uh
like somewhere but uh from human
perspective it's impo
possible but uh
very difficult to hold yeah so i have i
have many plans it's not yeah
so many setups you just secured the
d-pawn first and
then after you bring the king in
[Music]
so
i guess this is a question i actually
didn't see the end of the game live um
why not
i see so this was the point of this a45
so you have to give one of the pawns
um and then rook g3
and yes of course it's hopeless if black
gets the the duo so
well uh i mean you it has to be
calculated but yeah i i was calculating
like a little bit b6 for example
just
mine is faster mine are faster and maybe
even here uh do i have like rg5 maybe or
i don't know
yeah uh looks like or g5
i would i would recalculate maybe h5 is
stronger yeah so i i would i would
double check
um
so rick h36 and then so white does come
back to defend the g pawn
um and now you bring the king
rook b4 um and king d6 wow so apparently
the the engine
uh at least on you know low depths yeah
i think this is great i was calculating
this line
rugby seven rook g4 rook b6 king c5 rook
a6
uh
i think it was the best shot for him
like h5
yeah okay so h5 and okay i was
calculating uh i guess you know
that's where okay yes that's correct and
i i'm going to h4
right so and then after
a6 i guess you just couldn't communicate
be successful
so
i'm not sure if there's a
way to to try something else with white
yeah my my idea is simple i'm i'm
playing g5 and then i'm playing h3 and
rook h8 rook h4
i mean
oh yeah yeah
for example h3 and then up here yeah
that's good that's correct but you
always have to check like such moves
some nasty moves like c5 here
like yeah okay yeah
like this yes
and here i guess maybe is is good enough
but then there's a check and then a7
uh just a7 here yeah
okay a7 and right now you're not
concerned
well maybe you're you're you're on time
because you're g3 right here
but yeah i think maybe this move though
is oh it's a problem right you can oh
okay and a7 just a7 or just station and
i'm losing collection
yeah
so
yeah i get like as i said like c5 like
some nasty checks like you always have
to be you
always have to be careful but i was i
felt okay
yeah maybe here can you just uh
play a bit more simply just come come
back with the rook and skip behind the
pawns
but again it's uh it's very tricky i
i calculated until until h4 and i was
like okay at least i'm not losing and
again like i will calculate it uh later
but right
okay so so maybe maybe this was a try
for a while he just goes king b3 instead
and now i guess you uh yeah so uh
basically my general idea to
create uh past pawn and passport but not
immediately because i like in perfect
case and perfect word i would uh i would
like to have my rook behind the pawn so
that that was my goal but it's actually
it's very difficult so i like in the
game i kind of retreat my uh my pieces
and actually i went to g4 with my uh
i captured g4 with my kink and uh
interesting so i guess now this was just
going to be a worse version of what he
has gotten so he goes rook e4 to you
know sort of be consistent
and then h6 okay computer doesn't like
any of my money well um
maybe it it says richie one i'm not sure
i understand to be honest i haven't
looked at this enough but okay so look
for rookie one
on the same page
then you get checked comes back and okay
so you swing the rook over and now king
king d5
so now i'm combining ideas this move
sort of surprises me why would uh why
would king a4 be played over king c4
king c4 i uh maybe i can play rook b5
okay just just concrete
and rook f7 rook 5 rook g7 rook g5 so
okay
with two points i have more chances
right yeah and this this falls with
check okay
uh makes sense to me so he has to defend
the pawn but but now with the king's
sideline
you have to feel it like this small
factor is like i'm just
improving my position or making his
position worse so right now he has very
bad king
um so yeah now king d5 and it makes
sense from this point like
white has to be in lots of trouble if
they can be serious you can never really
do this because i guess you just take
and the end game is always winning so by
the way do you know how how many uh how
much king wars
how how much the king is worth i've
always heard a little more than four uh
oh okay you're very close like i had uh
this uh class in the university math and
chess yeah so actually it was calculated
and it was about four yeah just about
four so it's not priceless it's it's
it's because it's pretty good better
than a bishop yeah um
so yeah now i guess you just pick up the
g pawn and yes
uh yeah the rook is like he's not some
time to
to create counter play yeah so he goes
for c5 c6 uh just to to break things up
and and try to take this pawn but you
can't even capture here now
this must be must be over
and
that was that was enough
um so i guess the story of this this
game then was this kind of complex end
game but you seized the advantage with
uh after this f5 yeah of course
um in general what should white be be
doing here i guess f5 is the idea but
you just need to prepare this somehow
yeah um if i've one of the ideas maybe
maybe just king b1 like just a solid
improving move i also didn't like g4
like before yeah something like i don't
know like he had here like let's say
bishop f6 queen bishop f6 bishop to xf6
king queen g6 maybe this this line is
more or less i would be very nervous
about uh leaving my knight here for too
long uh like the point is uh
between the six let's say 36. no no
actually bishop c3 is better version
bishop city
first yeah because right now i'm keeping
queens oh yeah maybe yeah so and also
you couldn't uh you couldn't take on d8
first uh because i have russia
yeah so and
it's more or less take one five five yes
and i calculated
king b-2
bishop before doesn't work at least uh i
was uh english before yeah
i was thinking that it doesn't work and
i was going to play just queen b6 and
it's tricky move because after king
before okay king k1 probably the best
but yeah given before uh it's even
before queen e3 and
like it's like very problematic to
defend the spawn on f4 actually oh okay
yeah the threat's kind of mounted yeah
right g3 is no good together this
discovery doesn't go anywhere but i mean
maybe like f5 i just take and take on f3
okay yeah so
um so yeah pretty complicated game so
you mentioned um playing a lot of
openings that are a little bit outside
your normal repertoire maybe comfort
zone yeah so uh
is that kind of unique to these round
robin norm tournaments you think or uh
have you sort of found this happening in
all the tournaments you're playing now
uh actually it was recently i played in
uh charlotte and
also around robin tournament and for
like one guy like we were playing blitz
and one of the
player who told me that
explain me why i have i'm playing much
worse in round robin tournaments because
people actually preparing against me and
i i'm not
i'm not spending enough time actually to
prepare and i was like oh he's right so
i started just play like you know like
uh better uh to play that you don't know
and your opponent don't uh doesn't know
like yeah it's it's just better version
that
you don't know and your opponent
actually prepared so
yeah yeah
you're getting chess games and uh so far
it looks like that's been enough to
secure uh the win this time so any plans
for the the last round tomorrow um
actually one that's why i came today
my my former coach told me that uh never
give interviews until tournament is over
because you're gonna give interview
you're gonna lose the next day for sure
but okay i came here because i already
secured first place won the tournament
well my prediction it's not going to be
an easy game
all right well uh thank you for joining
us vladimir congratulations on on
winning the events uh pretty outstanding
chess i really enjoyed uh this game uh
was quite fun and i enjoyed i think it
was against uh evan park that game was
lots of yeah
that was my
that's my
actually favorite game of yeah i think
that's my favorite game of either event
i had a lot of fun looking at that one
all right so congratulations thanks for
joining us
and uh with vladimir leaving us i think
we're going to take a look at the
pairings for the im section
um so we have josh poshma up against
gabriela and tova on board one uh then
begin is taking on ezra chambers we've
got alice up against pedro uh one game
has already ended that is the game
between jennifer yu and julian prolaco
and we round out the section with matias
merrick against aaron grobinski so while
there's not too much left to play for in
the gm section there's no no more norm
candidates there
and the tournament has been determined
there is quite a bit to play for in the
international master section so our key
match up here is going to be this one
between matias merrick and aaron
gabinski aaron uh giving us some eye
contact with the camera there that was
fun um so matias of course has five and
a half uh aaron trails him by just a
half point with five out of seven
and so this game is going to be key to
determining the winner um the other key
matchup if i might say so myself is
going to be this one between josh postma
and gabriella and tova and the reason
for that if my sheet here is correct is
josh needs only one more point to secure
not only an im norm but the im title
this would be his third and final norm
and with it he would go home with with
the new title and that is the whole
point of the tournament um let's check
in on that key match up first and
foremost though we've got matias with
the white pieces here up against aaron
grobinski with the black pieces
um and it looks like uh a pretty complex
end game here if uh
my instincts are correct so black has um
these queen side pawns which is going to
be a more useful majority in most cases
than this three versus two on the king
side kind of tough to make a past pawn
with this structure for for white
now what does white have in exchange for
that well white has the bishop versus
the knight and i think this is going to
be a very useful bishop in this position
and on top of that due to the fractured
pawns around black's king black might
have to
deal with some some king safety issues
um so that's sort of the general feel
but jumping into specifics here it looks
like aaron is actually putting on the
pressure against white's king um pretty
immediately and i'm not so sure that's
uh
that white is generating enough threats
against black's king here
so let's talk about moves so black is
maybe immediately threatening this idea
of knight g4 check um and now if you
move the king away we come in with the
queen and if you go king f3 then this
this h pawn is hanging so that is
the challenge for white to solve what
are you doing about knight g4
and i don't have the answers to be
honest you can't really go h3 i think
uh
black can and will capture that pawn you
don't even have any invasion squares
and
yeah what's the story what's the story
let me cheat
um okay the story is queen to d5 every
other move black is better that makes
sense to me so why is queen d5 good
enough i wonder it says knight g4 king
f3 we just take on h2
and yeah nobody cares nobody cares about
being down a pawn that's how strong
bishops are so
from a human perspective tough to a
tough pill to swallow playing queen d5
here right you have the bishop your
heart is telling you that the black king
should be a bit weaker with these
fractured pawns and you know your bishop
ready to line up on this long diagonal
against the king but uh yeah the engine
says this is the only way to not be
substantially worse and it says after
king e2
i guess this pawn is taboo because your
knight gets a little bit sidelined
and okay wow the computer says this is
very very bad yep you actually can't
stop this pawn so that's the resource
that white is relying on here and now if
we come back with uh okay we can't play
knight g4 we give this check
and come out with the knights
then
draw is found by the almighty engine
okay so it looks like the engine just
very concretely is finding a way to
end the game into perpetually here i
have to say though not at all a natural
line not at all an intuitive line uh if
you ask me this queen d5 move would be a
very very nice find if matias is able to
find it however he only has 90 seconds
on the clock i'm not so sure that this
game is is going to be going matias's
way so if aaron does put on some
pressure here and manages to win this
game he would leave frog matias and
potentially end up in first place
depending on the outcome of josh's game
so there we see a move he plays this
move king f3 yeah so this was was not
what uh the almighty engine was was
saying was the way to go um that being
said it looks like you know it's sort of
dealing with this threat now if we go
knight g4
i suppose the idea might be just to play
this move h3 just uh kick this knight
out but now i'm sort of confused again
on what's going on here this actually
looks like checkmate okay probably this
is not the plan
um
maybe maybe maybe maybe this is the idea
and the players want to reach a friendly
friendly result like this
um
so how does black actually prove an
advantage here we can give a queen g4
check but i don't think it does a lot
maybe just knight f5 maybe this the
secondary idea bringing this knight to
this other active square i i'm not sure
where exactly you want to place this
queen it looks like it could get sort of
awkward and then i i am actually going
to play this move h5 with uh the black
pieces here
and
you know somehow it seems like some
pressure there's there's queen c6 ideas
there's there's a lot of moves that you
have to keep track of here uh with white
there's you know queen g4 in some
positions
uh
have to be careful
engine says
0.00 so there you go
um so with that why don't we take a
quick look at the prize fund for the
events uh see what we've got going on
there
uh we have nine thousand dollars at
stake in the grand master section of
course vladimir has already secured that
first place prize of two thousand
dollars but plenty left to play for with
those second third fourth and fifth
place prizes all being a bump above the
uh i guess kind of appearance fee uh you
get 600 bucks just for showing up and
playing all the games not too bad
uh and then over in the international
master section we have six thousand
dollars at stake twelve hundred dollars
for first place one thousand per second
seven hundred bucks for third also not
too bad for five days of chess
uh and i'm receiving word that alice lee
has potentially uh blundered in her game
against pedro rodriguez so let's see
what's going on here before i do any
cheating how did we get here
so alice had the white pieces here and a
rather uncomfortable position right so
you see this isolated d-pawn you think
that uh maybe
white is gonna be better because you can
pressure this but then you look at the
other uh pawns on the board and you look
at the minor pieces right this bishop is
ideally placed on g7 it's an unopposed
bishop it's going to give black some
pretty monstrous activity
and white has done a bunch of nonsense
on the king's side those weaknesses are
are going to be there for the rest of
the game
so alice tried king f2 trying to hold
everything together and then yeah this
nice move bishop ca by by pedro he's
just rerouting this bishop to more
active diagonals he has enough activity
that he's not really so concerned about
defending this pawn uh f4 is the choice
by alice so sort of trying to get our
own bishop into the game
we see queen b6 now uh bishop f3 bishop
f5
queen c3 rook c8 and and yeah all of the
black pieces now have sort of sprung to
life around this isolated pawn
um looks pretty good bishop e4 strikes
me as kind of strange but maybe there
was just no alternative you know of
course this was now a threat with the
pin being broken so bishop before we get
captures captures knight down to e2
queen e6 so black's still just searching
for a way to invade here we saw a check
right back to d1 and now rook c2 so okay
this move rook d1 is sort of surprising
to me you know i would be worried about
this move rick to c2 you know i i would
want to stop this rick from invading
stop ideas like queen c4 piling up
against this knight
so my first instinct would have
definitely been rook d2 here trying to
keep this this guy out
and then finding some way to reorganize
my pieces right maybe
maybe that that way doesn't exist
actually kind of sad but she goes rook
d1 instead allows rook c2 and now rook
c1 was her idea so she's trying to evict
this rook from the c file uh but of
course pedro is just going to leave it
there just plays rook b2 and now rook
over to f1 and i'm being told that one
of these moves was a blunder
um
unclear to me which one of these moves
was the actual blunder to me it looks
like black's position is is still just
kind of building up i don't see a
knockout puncher by any by any stretch
of the word uh but ideas like queen to
c4 are gonna look really really nasty
okay rook to b3 is what pedro goes with
i'm kind of curious about this move
queen to c4 right this looks like it
attacks the knight a lot of times i
guess rook f2 has to be the intention
and then maybe then maybe i play this
move i just want to bring this this rook
to the slightly awkward square and then
after this the queen has to leave
i can take stuff
this is coming looks good for pedro
regardless uh even in the game we're
getting something similar just with this
rook on f1 instead of f2 so it looks
good for pedro he might just pick up
this pawn on a3 uh perhaps there are
some ideas of b5 in the air as well but
i'm also receiving a word in our other
key game in the im section that uh josh
pushma might be doing suddenly very very
well so we of course had this complex
position where josh had this knight on
e5 against the bishop's pair
and the queensland majority against the
kingside majority we saw this slightly
strange-looking knight to d7 somehow
trapping this bishop in the middle of
the board uh nowhere to go to save this
piece so josh was looking perhaps to get
one of the bishops off the board always
a good idea to remove one of the bishops
when the the strong bishop pair is
glaring down on your position
and he chooses actually to keep the
knight interestingly i think this is
josh sort of playing for a win here
right you could go takes on c5 play
something like queen c3 bring this
bishop back and play this opposite
colored bishop end game um
but instead he chooses to go for bishop
e3 leaving the knight on the board where
it's already nicely placed to challenge
this pawn on b6 and maybe he felt that
this was giving him some winning chances
so bishop c6 played in the game uh josh
does actually pick up that extra pawn
now and now interesting move knight to
c8 so of course my first instinct would
have been this but i think queen to g5
is putting on some nasty pressure also
defending against any invasions so
instead josh comes up with this weird
looking move knight c8 knight to the
back row
uh black picks the pawn back up but now
what's this queen d8 97 and that's a
checkmate threat
so black plays
bishop e 8 losing a piece was there no
other answer
i guess there was no other answer right
maybe she thought h5 or something but
check
check
check
and if not checkmate very very close and
actually i think this is
uh the disgusting move to end the game
g3 checkmate unstoppable or queen g3
unstoppable if you decide to pin me
sad sad story so h5 no good so she comes
up with bishop e8 gives this check gives
this check gives this check and i think
she's just hoping for some kind of
perpetual here the point of bishop b8
was to draw the queen off of the d-file
to the worst square of e8 and then hope
that she can trap this this king
in a perpetual check
now is it true is it going to be
perpetual i remain unconvinced i think
queen d6 and you actually have already
run out of checks with the move king h4
coming up the board towards the enemy
king towards the opposition but uh
somehow remaining safe if g5
king h5 even further up the board and
now you actually are
just out of checks
uh now can gabriella still try to
survive with some king g7
check
maybe maybe the answer is is maybe
uh i guess you have to go for something
like this you know like knight c8 i can
start making threats
and
maybe it's not so clear maybe it's not
so clear
so king g7 probably we need something
better with uh with the white pieces
here
now what is that uh what is that better
option
unclear to me
this knight's just sort of sort of
trapped over here if you try to secure
your knight again queen g3 is going to
come
looks scary so maybe maybe josh is not
super happy with this idea of of king h5
i think maybe king g4 is somehow more
accurate and now if we we try the exact
same thing my king is a little bit less
checkmated
i don't think you're so happy about this
one because now i do have a lot more
options with my pieces for example
i can even do this
and some very strange looking knight
to g8
queen g3 though again
yeah it just takes some calculations
okay so this one this one would be
winning
so king h4 is on the board we'll see if
if gabriella does play this move g5 i
think this has to be what you try i
don't know what else you can go for
um
and then it'll be interesting to see
where josh decides to put the king
because king h5 king g7
you know i'm sure there's an answer here
but i i just don't see it yet i i just
don't see it
which is always concerning you know
cause
when you're playing over the board uh
somehow it's it's not so easy
the line i showed with king on h5 and
king g7 was just mate
um
i'm interested to see where the mate is
queen g8 king king f6
and knight c8s queen g3 and
where where's the checkmate you can
check me around a little bit but i can
come back
check me from this direction i'll come
up
and that is
uh not checkmate right
and no other checks and then you have a
problem
how's julian doing today uh not so good
he lost his game against jennifer yu
before we went live here
um okay wow so josh does just go king h5
so g5 check king h5 on the board now it
must be king g7 there's there's simply
no other move here every other move is
is checkmate so kg7 i imagine
oh queen d1 check
queen d1 check
but just g4
but just g4 and that is the end of the
game
jennifer yu has resigned so she didn't
think king g7 was worth trying clearly
i'm missing something king g7 check here
knight c8 queen g3
oh i'm sorry gabriella and tova not not
jennifer you oh this is mate in three
houses oh 97 i missed 97 and then
checkmate so there you go
uh as always
not so good at calculating on the fly um
so she went queen d1 now g4 and that's
that's going to be the end of the game
uh so with that i believe that brings
josh to six and a half points
which if my paper here is correct that
is the im title so congratulations josh
postuma becomes an im in st louis the
story of the im section and on top of
that uh secures at least a tie for first
going into the final round so of course
you know he's not guaranteed tied first
place but going into the final round he
will at least be tied for first
meanwhile what's going on in our key
matchup maybe we'll get josh down here
for an interview
but yeah
king f3 uh white d or black did go for
this queen h3 idea and then bishop b2 so
again this looks tempting right it seems
like the black king should be the one
that's weak here but after queen f1
check aaron it looks like has found a
very very dangerous line checks the
white king up the board goes queen c6
queen takes c4 that's an extra pawn
and
to my eyes that looks like a win for
aaron grobinski so our tournament leader
might be falling to aaron gorbinski one
of the highest rated players in the
section i think he trails uh the new
newly crowned i am josh poshma uh by
just a few rating points uh but so far
having a very good tournament
um
yeah and i i sort of got the feeling
that this would happen the engine giving
this queen d5 move just felt so
so strange you know queen d5 is weird
you want this queen sort of pressuring
this this black king queen d5 is a hard
move to play um and then after queen h3
supposedly queen d3 again was the way to
go just not at all caring about this guy
because you know this is checkmate okay
this is
yeah this this wouldn't happen
um so because you can't come up the
board and knight f7
runs into queen g4
uh you have to go back and that
apparently is the draw for white
so just queen d3 guarding against all
the checks making queen h5 the only
reasonable check and then sort of
playing for the draw here um honestly
though from a human perspective tough to
to play for the draw with white here
right you've got this nice bishop you
look like it looks like you're
pressuring the black king and then
suddenly out of nowhere you're fighting
for your life not a not an easy switch
to make especially psychologically and
yeah aaron of course playing the knight
to the corner uh you love to see it
so
we'll see if aaron can secure victory
here we just now see this move bishop e5
that is capturable i believe i don't
think there's any miracle draws here
maybe f5 is is what he's intending
trying to cut the king off and and come
after him but at the worst case you know
knights are very very good defenders of
the king you can even go with with
knight g8 and king h8 and
look at that no more checks look at that
beautiful construction of the pieces
so i do believe aaron will be securing
the victory here i don't know if he'll
go for the capture of this bishop but uh
looks like he'll be doing uh very very
well
and i'm not sure what the the last round
matchup is is going to be in the im
section i i don't recall a game between
josh and aaron
uh that's right that's the final game
and here we have josh joining us in the
studio and it will be a final matchup
between josh and aaron uh for all the
marbles uh assuming this game goes the
way it looks to be going so first of all
josh congratulations that's the ien
title right six and a half points you
did it uh so what does it mean to do it
here in st louis on your first visit i
think too my first visit i'm i'm so
happy i'm so happy i've been working for
this title for like four years since
hitting fm yeah and it's it's you know
not an easy 100 points to climb not an
easy three norms to get at all
definitely but um i have really enjoyed
playing here in st louis it's just you
know
absolutely amazing so well huge
congratulations and uh your job's not
over yet you still have to win the
tournament correct that is
that would be good you don't want to be
the guy that gets the norm and then the
last round doesn't win the tournament
right right clearly you have to so of
course uh walk me through this last game
that you just played here it looks like
a very interesting finish so we started
off of course in the slav and you went
for the the quiet sloth so correct uh
i've been told that this line is
surprisingly dangerous for black is i
guess that must be
absolutely your impression right i in
the semi-slav especially yeah i think
there's a lot of
venom uh so this is actually i got my
first uh gm uh victory in this line with
knight bd2 so yes so what's the idea of
this this move then because you know to
my beginner eyes right c3 square pretty
good square for a knight
d2 square not it's not as good of a
square right so why are you going here
so the idea is that in the [ __ ] lines
where you go knight c3 yeah and then you
know later you'll develop your bishop to
d3 right let's say knight bd7 bishop d3
um black will wait for you to develop
the bishop then they'll take on c4 make
you spend another tempo with your tempo
and they'll play b5 make you spend a
third tempo with your bishop
and
somewhere yeah and you know that's fine
of course but the idea with knight bd2
is to kind of discourage that because
we're always going to be happy to take
back with the knight and improve it to a
better square i see so knight bd7 you do
develop your bishop now and so black is
not doing this anymore because correct
because then from b5 i wouldn't have to
retreat to d2 i could go hop into a
better square yeah and start invading
okay so bishop b7 instead uh you get
castle castles and then immediately e4
so you're breaking in the center yep
um you know black should should capture
uh you know my impression is allowing
something like this not not so funny not
good so it takes on e4
uh and then immediately c5 yes so this
is this is often what i i tell people uh
about uh openings where you give away
the center you know it's fine to give
away the center but you have to get it
back so you have to fight back so c5 and
you went for this line with knight take
c5
which does allow black to simplify a
little bit but you end up in this this
structure
so you have three palms on each side
versus you know this
so
uh was this sort of the plan going in
were you expecting a position like this
no i was expecting her to play bishop d6
instead of bishop e7 a few moves back so
bishop seven got me out of out of my
prep so so way back here we thought
bishop decent yeah so that's the main
move i guess right right and then
there's some different stuff but um yeah
this is a pretty good line for black um
i think this was probably her
preparation because i had a game back in
january against uh um
let's see who
abi manumisha
in this exact line that's where i got
like no advantage it just fizzles out to
a draw yeah so she was probably trying
to follow that and in that game i went
bishop g5 okay so that's the number one
which is the main move but um i actually
in the in this game i spent a long time
in this position because i didn't want
to just play the same thing i played
before right and continue
falling for her preparation yeah this is
what sort of vladimir was talking about
in his interview is uh especially in
these round robin norm tournaments
preparation is a huge huge deal compared
to open tournaments for sure so you came
up with with queen e2 which has been
played a number of times
um b6 seems sensible right just getting
developed
so natural moves for a little bit here
so rick d1
might as well get the queen out of the
way
and yeah it looks like in the two games
in the database here queen c7 was the
choice right which maybe this
contributed a little bit to the little
bit of pressure you got because now
after bishop g5 still kind of stuck in a
pin
um
and so i guess take me to the point
where you thought that things started to
go in your direction
well um they started to go not in my
direction for a little while
and i thought 95 was gonna be really
good because i've got ideas of knight g4
potentially
you know i've got ideas of uh trading on
f6 and going knight d7 yeah but then i
realized she plays rook d8 right away
and i realized stopping knight d7 yeah
knight g4 is just met by bishop d4
i've got nothing ah
so this nice rerouting of the bishop
yeah you see this quite a bit yeah um
and then tough to play move here i guess
yeah it is it's just probably trades and
it's equal yeah you take take take and
if if you'd rather be anybody you might
start to think about being black with
this nice bishop here on on b7 um
so
no knight g4 then no i thought for a
long time and played rook d2 which uh is
not a move that i'm happy with right so
i mean it it's uh you know
optimistically double on the d file you
know things simplify a little bit too
optimistic
yeah the problem here is i was planning
to meet h6 with bishop h4 right and then
i realized rook d4
is really annoying this d4 square seems
to be the common problem yeah this is
what i missed that it's a tempo on my
bishop and the original plan well yeah
if i just drop back and she doubles on
the d file
um you've sort of lost this race right
and because i also have to worry about
bishop b4 at any point ruining my
coordination yeah bishop b4 there's
there's stuff on the e4 square to look
out for as well i thought i'd be worse
here yeah it looks scary looks scary so
so you you solved your d4 square
problems
i guess so but you can see the time
situation here i'm down to 20 24 minutes
yeah it took some time so
uh yeah at this point i was feeling like
hey okay i things have gone wrong i'm
slightly worse and i'm down an hour
so then rook d6 so yeah yeah i guess
this move bishop b4 is is what the the
computer said on low depth at least and
to my eyes this makes a lot of sense and
then your rook d2 moves i thought i
would have to just go back to d1 yeah
just just back to d1 yeah i don't think
you really play rook c2 ever here no i
wanted to do that and then go a3 and
then hope to go back but maybe maybe do
something
but didn't believe it though okay
so
uh after rook to d6 i guess you
correctly pointed out why this move is
not so good because no more bishop
before correct yes and i get to go b4
unless she spends the tempo to stop it
yeah so a3 you get that kind of for free
because a5 is um
maybe not completely necessary but
important to stop your your idea of
getting the the space on the queen side
and now you know your optimistic uh play
has worked out
yeah yeah you got what you were
envisioning so rick 88 and so now you
just play this nice move h3 just sort of
sitting right
okay so bishop a8 bishop c2 queen b7
um she made a threat so you stopped it
it takes d2 takes and now queen over to
c7
and didn't look like much here all right
so uh how do you try to generate
something in a position like this
well one thing that i would love to
accomplish is getting in the b4 pawn
break and mobilizing my queen side
majority um the other
plan that i could come up with was to
target the b6 pawn right okay so a5 has
made a little weakness here
so you're thinking either you find a way
to target that or you find a way to get
the a passed pawn and you get something
to play for yeah and if i could get some
imbalance uh if i could get
the bishop pair or something you know
get a favorable trade in that would or
if i could infiltrate to d8 with a queen
or something you know that was another
way i could try to get an advantage so
you came up with bishop f4 trying to
sort of shake loose black's hold on the
d file i guess so rook d2 queen d2 queen
e7 um and then you came up with this
nice idea of knight back to e5 and i was
really interested by your decision of
how to deal with this bishop on c5 which
i guess is coming up here in a little
bit so black plays this move knight e4
and tell me about bishop takes knight uh
i have to
you have to otherwise f2 falls oh well
so i guess well you saw this coming then
with knight e5 i did i did
rather than play a move like queen e2 um
you thought just give up the bishop for
the night and no worries
no worries because of the follow-up that
i had in mind i knew that black wouldn't
be able to keep the bishop pair fair
enough so yeah knight d7 um yeah this is
the follow-up you're talking about so
you immediately target this bishop on c5
but then the move that i found maybe to
be one of the most interesting was the
decision to go bishop e3 here rather
than just capturing this bishop so yeah
tell me about that
well if i capture the bishop
it's opposite colored bishops yep and i
thought it would be very very drawish
okay uh and i really wanted to win this
game so all right um the original plan
here was actually bishop to c7 to target
the b6 pawn keeping everything on i
calculated bishop c6
bishop takes b6 i thought at first would
win a pawn but black has a desperado
bishop takes f2 ah okay
right and then again it's opposite color
bishops they have my pass pawn firmly
blockaded right yeah exactly i thought i
have a pass pawn but it's going nowhere
right this is just going to be a draw
right yeah and i guess in in these lines
probably queen you can try to go uh
queen c3 or something
i thought maybe you would go here here
try and take something but uh
potentially but if
b5 right now for example yeah i'm
already forced to trade and my extra
pawn on the queen side doesn't it
doesn't look very good now yeah so takes
probably black just takes the pawn back
but then you know this is not not going
anywhere yeah so you came up with bishop
e3 to try and keep chances alive um so
now rather than uh trading the knight
for the bishop you get the bishop for
the bishop um f takes e3 and to my eyes
this structure is actually pretty good
right
no
terrible uh no it's not it's not a great
structure i wouldn't say my king is
exposed now the e3 pawn is isolated and
could be weak um i justified it because
i thought i was just winning the v6 pawn
by force okay fair enough and i think i
am um
yeah
the the point i was trying to make is
that this lateral defense could actually
be
quite helpful whereas in sort of this
structure
um okay let's let's play some nonsense
moves let's say it takes takes and
you're back here um immediately you know
things like uh
you know let's say knight b6 immediately
things like queen b7 are going to start
to be tricky and you're you're not uh
defending your g pawn like okay i mean
even
i don't know if this works there could
be tactics like that potentially yes yes
yeah so uh i i like this fe move just
because it it sort of allows for this um
so black came up with bishop c6 and you
were correct you're just taking b6
immediately then after queen to c5
um this is where it sort of all fell
apart
uh the next move is where it fell apart
i was happy with the move that i came up
with here because um i i was thinking
originally this is just gonna be a draw
um if if i go queen d4 which was the
original plan she goes queen g5 yeah and
you still have these issues here and i
have to go back
i mean there's no
um i thought about e4 but well she could
even take it awkward she could even take
it and then go uh queen to c5
potentially
yeah this this looks i have a pass pawn
yeah that's true that's true maybe
there's another way she could play
something yeah i'm not sure
that's true there's chances if um you
know there's chances here yeah passive
pawn is good
um
but yeah to your point you came up with
a better move so you know queen d4 may
be okay but the engine will probably say
they're both equal but i thought this
was really tricky knight to c8 and so it
looks at first glance like your knight
is hanging in a lot of different ways
um so what were you uh what were you
calculating here what was what were you
expecting well i calculated
exactly what happened in the game pretty
much that was good yes i would uh this
tactically saves my c4 pawn yeah um i
was also calculating any discoveries
like bishop takes g2 i have the inter in
between move queen d8 right so if you
capture then black can capture but you
go check and take and then and then
there's no perpetual no queen g5 check
or anything like that my queen has that
covered yeah um yeah and then it looks
like the computer is the computer and it
says you know i'm not scared of being
down a piece i'm gonna check you forever
and then etc that's
fair
my knight is very out of play and it's
not not that easy to play over the board
right you know us as humans were a
little bit more reluctant to just give
away her pieces for free yeah
so she did play queen c4 in the game
which loses to what was played so i was
sort of surprised to see this move
because it looks
sort of right away like um like black is
just just busted
yeah she was in time pressure
she was actually she was about to play
king h7 and then uh the last second she
uh changed her mind so i got so king h7
here yeah which i think is a is a pretty
good try um i was just gonna go knight
d6 i think and uh
yeah so now now that this isn't with
check uh black of course is is getting
active counter play so knight d6 and
then okay you have an extra pawn um
and the game continues i guess
right uh maybe even king back to g8 here
yeah defend that seven point interesting
way to go
uh but instead
you end in glory knight to e7 and i was
having some fun looking at these lines
where uh
uh you know looking at like king g7 oh i
didn't even see king g7 oh my goodness
okay and here i was looking at knight c8
queen g3 but
uh you do you do have have the win here
uh queen h8 knight no no
uh yeah queen h8 knight e7 and d4 knight
e7 queen d4 there we go and i didn't see
97 i was staring at this for like uh
three minutes at least and i was like 96
no good
white is lost
yeah but so the the chat room sort of
had the answers for me so we got there
in the end um yeah i thought she would
definitely try queen g7 i was very
surprised to see sequin d1 because i
thought you know it stopped not so easy
both totally missed that move yeah like
you have to play this knight c8 and then
wow you know it's like okay like there
are a number of ways to do it but
maintenance iii gonna be good enough
here actually made in one in the in this
case when we have the pawn on g4 queen
h8 right
so yeah queen d1 no good queen g3 though
that's tricky that's all right but all
was well you know there there is justice
in the world sometimes
you can't play like this and not get
checkmated with black
like so you got there in the end king g7
uh was not played queen d1 g4 and then
she she ended up resigning here
so uh is this your favorite game of your
chess career
um no
i mean i i it's memorable of course it's
gonna be memorable being uh the my final
game to earn the im title um i don't
think it was the smoothest game or
anything like that um but i am happy
with a few things i'm happy with knight
c8 and um
and
yeah a very nice finish as well so do
you have white or black against aaron
tomorrow i've got black against aaron
all right well you just if you hold him
to a draw then uh then you will walk
away the champion
oh yeah that's right that's right okay
okay see what i can do thank you very
much for joining us international master
elect josh posthumour congratulations
again uh and good luck in in your final
game tomorrow all right thank you caleb
thanks
oh there he is brand new i am josh
poshma you love to see it um so with
that we do have a couple games remaining
here in the day we've got two games in
the im section that we'll keep an eye on
and two games in the gm section um i was
interested in what was going on in this
alice lee game against pedro things have
really blown up here
by blown up i mean just every pawn on
the board has disappeared for alice but
she didn't get checkmated yet
um
so how did we get here we left it after
this move
uh yeah rook b3 to a3 and then white
came up with this idea of f5 actually so
alice uh you know these pawns in front
of her king actually not giving her all
that much shelter so she figured why not
uh break up black's pretty little
structure as well and get some counter
play
i had mentioned this move b5 uh sort of
offhand i i think this move rook a5 is
the response and and why that wasn't
played otherwise this would have been an
interesting idea hit the rook maybe
trade off these queen side pawns try to
hole up get some kind of fortress on the
king's side she goes for f5 instead
queen a2 now we take on g6 take on g6
and rookie 1.
so pretty scary stuff trying to hold on
to this pinned knights queen to b3 now
making some threats over here king to g1
stepping out of the check
rook a2 back and yeah now g4 so alice uh
again her king is weak so she's figuring
you know i might as well try to make my
opponent's king weak as well and try to
get my counter play uh against
the monarch
okay so in the game uh black picks up
this b4 pawn as well we see another
check and
now we are at the current position so a
minute 50 on the clock for alice minute
30 on the clock for uh
pedro here and pedro is two pawns to the
good now the bad news is they're both
rook pawns so of course you can imagine
you know this i think would definitely
not be pedro's best idea uh if you trade
off these guys you know this pawn uh not
going to be on the best square for black
if the rooks get traded and i can
sacrifice my knight for this a pawn run
my king to this corner and i never lose
the game so not at all going to be an
easy end game to win for pedro here the
good news is with two major pieces on
the board and white having literally no
shelter for the king
i think he's going to be able to use
that to his advantage keep playing
against this knight this bishop in this
pawn they don't provide much shelter for
the black king but they do provide sort
of enough so i'm expecting like
maybe queen g6 here with the idea being
to just uh come after the king although
alice might be very direct play queen d3
trying to trade trade these guys off but
there are there are still resources here
to uh to keep things keep things on the
board with black
um
so we do actually have moves um queen to
b6 check was played rather than queen g6
and now queen e3
and
i think we're gonna leave this one
because this is an end game it'll it'll
take some time
maybe caleb gets fm tomorrow definitely
not because i'm not playing tomorrow
okay let's check on the other game going
on in the im section we've got the game
against ezra paul chambers
uh so what's the story here we've got
rook and knight versus rick and knight
and the game has this nice f pawn
that she's going to try to use to win
the game
and i think she will succeed uh
difficult to touch any of the black
pieces here if you move this knight
somewhere i think this just ends the
game on the spot checkmate is pretty
strong
so she needs this knights or sorry ezra
needs this knight here so that after
king e6 uh we have knight f4 with check
so that's why this knight's on g2
black tries to go with c5 trying to
potentially distract some of the white
pieces by creating a past pawn
but i think this one's only a matter of
time i think this move f5 is pretty
desirable and
now
you know we can even sort of keep it
simple here
check ands go go go go go go go
not sure what black is doing against
this idea i think you can just win
just win very concretely like you know
there's there's a check
can go here
and
okay maybe i'm you know
maybe i'm not playing the most
accurately but
i seem to be winning
okay
so not so good for ezra uh i think if
you ask the engine it will say the same
thing plus seven pretty good what does
it think about my plan
this way
f5
and yes c4 take take f6
f7 f8 all pretty good
yeah i was going rookie seven here
it says it's mate in eight so pretty
good for begin
um and i think scoresheets are actually
being signed uh so it looks like the
game has won by resignation uh ezra not
gonna see this one through just a
tough finish
um okay so with that begin i think moves
on to a very respectable score as well
um i think she has
uh four and a half might have made that
up i think she's like plus one
um
and the chatroom is asking me are you
absolutely sure that alice can draw that
end game
down
uh draw that two pawn down position with
a queen trade well we're gonna find out
because queen g6 was played queen d3 was
played in my move rookie four did not
make an appearance um
pedro did decide to trade the queens and
then went a5
that is a very confusing move that is a
very very very confusing move rook d5 on
the board is attacking two pawns at the
same time
maybe
maybe uh this is winning if you just
like defend your pawn
but
yeah a5 rook d5 like one of these pawns
falls now and at the very very very
least
we're getting um
rook and bishop versus rook which you
know obviously is going to be a
difficult uh
uh difficult endgame to hold but should
be a draw nonetheless and i'm not even
so sure you get that here with with
black i mean you go rook a5
and how how do you advance your pawn
like you go bishop b2
um and we might get the game for an
interview
[Music]
sounds like she might be available
bishop b2 and i mean you can you can try
to push this guy
i'm going to bring my king over
and a3 i guess bring my king over again
hard to push this guy any further right
hard to get much further with with black
here
um meanwhile in the gm section we have
interesting things going on here as well
of course we we saw vlad's game which
ended in victory
uh we also have evan park against uh
ivan which this is looking
um kind of familiar uh looks a lot like
the ellis lee game actually um so this
one should also be a draw it looks like
although this i think is significantly
harder with the b pawn rather than an a
pawn and the the white king well
positioned to help defend the pawn you
know this one looks like it might
actually go to rook and bishop versus
rook which is where you can save for the
other game
uh and the last game that we still have
in progress is this one between uh
victor modericion and uh koscielkovitsky
uh and it looks like victor is in the
final stages of trying to convert this
this rook versus knight end game here uh
the king is cut off the the knights is
not going to be able to stop this pawn
effectively and should be a win
and i think we are getting the game here
in the studio to talk about her win
against ezra chambers that just happened
um
and so without further ado hello welcome
to the show the game have you have you
been on the show yet uh no all right
well congratulations on the win today
this brings you to plus one in the event
uh guess so yeah um finally yes so uh
tell me uh about your game today uh how
are you feeling uh well i have a feeling
that after the opening i was much better
yep so
of course we got there through
this sort of this is a tricky move order
yeah so queen b3
and of course whenever you know black
develops the bishop out early outside
the pawn chain sometimes the light
squares fall victim so queen b6 here to
defend b7 and then
yeah d3 knight b87
and after knight goes to this one i have
to take on the d5 i guess this is a nice
move order because knight
cannot come to c6 anymore so okay so
yeah now the point is after c takes d
you know black would love to play knight
right now
white should be a bit better because
this knight is misplaced yeah okay so e
takes instead
and queen c2 okay this is a little bit
tricky because uh if bishop d6 then i
can play e4
okay so
he cannot really put bishop d6 or bishop
c5 and
i so how does this one go if takes takes
bishop g6 i mean i just have an
advantage yes already like knight c3 i i
just put my p pieces rook t1 bishop e3
everything's just coming no no center
pawn for black yeah so bishop d6 is not
so good so bishop b7 and stuff
black
like how how to play queen c5 it looks
very nice for uh like for black 25 okay
so your queen of course position because
i'm threatening e4 and after queen c5 i
cannot play knight c3 so he's putting
some problems right uh i see okay so
your queen is just well placed here on
c2 to support e4 so you think this was
the way that black needed to solve these
problems and then it looked a little bit
worse for him after e4 like knight c3 h6
e4
um so is it too late to go for for this
idea now yeah we should be three yeah
just bishop e3 and bishop d4 e4 is
coming in okay so
uh you do break through with e4 now and
i guess this is a lot like what we were
looking at yeah it seemed very nice for
me maybe bishop e3 wasn't so good maybe
rook d1 immediately is better um why is
that uh because uh i want to put my
queen somewhere on e2 probably and then
play e5 right okay and then rook should
be on the d1 but i'm not sure about the
bishop yet yeah so bishop e3 might
interfere with with your queen e2 idea
because uh you need the support of the
pawn style probably it's a bit better
for me i don't know yeah i mean there
should be three set up also looks looks
quite good though right yep um so queen
a6 and you just bring the rook to the
natural square
um so
i'm going to be playing
yeah so it
okay so i guess your ideas were
revolving around e5 right that's what
you're saying so uh to do that you
brought the queen out to b3 yeah is
there anything like elsa movie i have
not checked this game with maybe just
computer but yeah
it looks like in the database a number
of things have been tried just something
like a3 just sort of yeah i have an
advantage i must mess it up i had the
feeling that i shouldn't go to these
like force lines okay
um so queen b3 is very forcing because
you know you have these problems on
youtube
so
knight c5
attacking both things
and you got the pin wait is it still a
theory um oh my god two people played
yeah it looks like there's a jumbo uh
juma bayev game here actually um i would
i would not have guessed to be honest i
didn't know the position i just woke up
i like checked
his games i was like okay i'm just
playing this line we'll see
so
okay so queen before and and black has
to solve these problems somehow to get
counter play here so it looks like queen
b6 and you're still following this game
queen c4
probably they repeated the moves right
queen yes so queen e6 oh actually it
looks like in the gimbap if game this
this was played
amazing
you guys you guys are just the best
um knight a6 and fortunately for you
jumabayev was had an advantage in this
game it looks like um so juba have came
up with this move knight eve yeah i
wanted to play knight five to be honest
i don't know why i didn't do that i was
very tempted to play e5 because that's
how i like i wanted to play e5 for a
while yeah that's been your idea leading
up to this point but when i i got the
position i really wanted to play knight
t5 but i wasn't sure about bishop c5
after knight e5 yeah so i mean this was
a very strong bishop so it's kind of
feels bad to let it go i guess yeah um
but i guess structurally here it's it's
just quite good for you yeah that's what
this is coming to right yeah the the
knights don't have squares and your
knights kind of do have squares anyways
i still got something similar but with
my pawn on e5 which was worse a little
bit sure for me um so this knight came
out to g4
uh bishop d4 and now f6 okay so it looks
like black is is sort of getting active
compared to this otherwise yeah position
though okay
okay
oh and we'll get back to this game but
it looks like we do have a result in the
alice lee game
against peter rodriguez that game has
been agreed to a draw so we saw there at
the ends
um the sort of strange move a5 just uh
allowing this double attack of the pawns
and any winning chances that were left
sort of go away after one of these pawns
oh my god the light was winning here
um black was at least a lot better it
looks like
way way back um we had this position
which looked kind of
very very bad and then it sort of got
simplified and then i i really disagreed
with um pedro's decision to let the
queen's off the board here i i felt like
you just missed uh queen
like yeah
i thought even here you can go rookie
four um and try to keep pieces on but uh
he went for the pure end game and then
after a5 it's
there's just nothing to do probably
that's why yep
um but let's let's check back in on your
game so we saw e5 bishop d4 and then
yeah black somehow is finding squares
for the pieces again yeah um so you sort
of have to win again now um i know i was
a little bit tonight i was like oh my
god if i was such a like a stupid move
to be honest i was like what i did
i saw the position i
i had a feeling that i'm faster than i
started to realize i just don't have
anything
so what was the the next critical moment
would you say probably um
when he played bishop g6 so uh yeah
black comes out with bishop c5 and these
moves just all seem very logical and
normal uh both players just bring their
pieces in the game so this f3 move i
thought was was pretty interesting so i
really liked it yeah i saw the move i
was like there's no way that i'm not
making it yeah i just really wanted to
play it so of course what's the main
point here i mean i'm controlling e4
square and i'm not uh
like giving him easily exchange the
pieces and he has the time trouble he
needs to figure out where to put uh put
his pieces which is not easy right yeah
so you're making a thread as well right
with yeah and b4 is coming too but of
course you can protect a5 yes
this induces a5
um and then it's just a matter of
getting your pieces in the game i guess
yeah unfortunately still i don't have
anything i was
like very curious you can go ahead so
here's special g6 yeah i was uh curious
if if i should play a3 a4 then like f4
or immediately f4 probably a3 would be
better because a4 in some lines i i can
take on a4 knight a4 tags
so um just okay so something like four
after that for example he played e8
right um
so yeah we didn't include yeah if you
included bishop c4
okay king f8
itech
on e8
okay and then yeah are there immediate
problems no king takes on okay okay so
take on e8 and then unfortunately yeah
it's the same position but uh in this
line i guess
yeah rook takes f5
and then we shut up someone i can now i
can't think of knight e6 even you know
yeah and a4 is hanging it it definitely
looks like black's pieces have somehow
been been misplaced and then pawn is
hanging at something so something like
this and but of course these things are
not forced
this is hanging now so
scary scary stuff
um but then just uh
it takes i guess 95. it looks very
complicated i don't know it looks very
equal to me um
so
yeah so you thought it might be useful
to include a3 just because then this
pawn is going to be yeah
it could be good then these lines should
be very similar i guess so you follow
more or less the game
uh with this king f8 and takes takes and
now f5 yeah
um so here rather than go for 96 uh you
you just take on
yeah 96 pounds just makes lessons here i
guess this is right again for myself
yeah so it takes
um and now 96 because you have uh this
idea yeah um so g6 by black trying to
maybe keep six was better just he's not
giving me any weaknesses or any squares
he can play g6 literally any time yeah i
mean i guess you go g4 right g4 then he
can take on it e6 no
rook d7 knight c5
yeah um it looks better it seems
reasonable yeah
i was like after king f6 i couldn't uh
like find much for white
yeah i wasn't sure what to do yeah i
mean this pawn is attacked i guess so
it's either g4 or or
you know trade and do something but so
it's not easy so g6 instead and you
thought that this might just be creating
sort of a harder weakness for you for
black that's why i decided to just go
back
i want to save some pieces now i have
weakness on h6 and maybe that's like a5
b7 structure is not just the best yeah
you have some targets yeah um so knight
f6 in the game um you come with king g2
and take sticks
i don't know where he did wrong to be
honest at some point he just collapsed
his position
oh and um we have more breaking news uh
kosciu has resigned in his game against
victor maviation um so we sort of saw
this coming in the rook versus night end
game but we'll continue on here uh so i
had a four king of seven and you said
you weren't quite sure where you went
wrong yeah um so did you feel you felt
that you were pressing here though right
i mean of course if anyone's trying to
win yeah sure i'm pressing but like at
some point just black's position just
collapsed it was very like surprising
yeah so we got rick d6 95 and then black
simplified a little bit and goes knight
g6
um
and then yeah yeah you just have
to really take the pawn because rook is
going to be very bad on a5
um yes so much time
rook d5 here and you're saying that uh
you know i guess you do take on a5 but
but here it's uh it's different because
his rook is not active i don't know yeah
this one rick d5 sort of seems he
doesn't have time unfortunately that's
why he just like he needed to make a
move yeah um so this tournament of
course is just 90 plus 30 no extra time
um so
it seems like maybe you're using that to
your advantage uh yeah because it's
easier for me to play this position and
black has to defend somehow yeah
so
yeah it looks like things have have
already gone pretty wrong here um in my
opinion maybe this move it's just uh
like probably it's possible to defend it
but it's not that easy yeah maybe with
black hair
were you considering ideas of of him
just kind of trying to push and simplify
on the side of the board yeah he he
needed to do that i thought it's the
only chance he has yeah this this whole
concept with with 96 then then i guess
this b3 move is very clever right you're
just locking down the queen side a
little bit locking down this weakness on
a5 and he shouldn't play on on the king
side right right play on queen side
which he didn't do
yeah so after you win this a5 pun i i
think practically it's it's almost
impossible with with no time so
um we were both like playing last
seconds so it's very hard to defend you
know it was funny at some i i was about
to play knight f5 actually instead of
knight e4
i was terrified to see that knight f6 is
just
oh no oh no
yeah that would have been an end to the
game
the game is still so tricky that's
that's why i had to i had to be a little
bit careful yeah it's it's always
not not so easy with with the kids
yeah um
but i thought the way you handled it
looks looks very very clean you just
advance the king and then you know this
is obviously just just yeah it's just
um
you just captured on c5 which is sort of
the simplest i guess in time pressure i
was just looking at the very directs
just just go go go yeah i had a feeling
it should be easier than taking on c5
and then i i said okay i don't have time
let's just take on c5 first and start to
think like nothing to calculate if you
take c5 whereas here like i mean you get
checked and you're like ah
and then knight f4 knight h5 all these
things coming it's just yeah
it's winning but it's all right
no this is a pretty good rule i think um
victor uh blues uh
uh was also saying this where he tells
the students like if you don't need to
calculate then just don't calculate just
choose
when you have
30 seconds you just make a move right
you take your pawn and then you think
all right well very nice game the game
uh who do you have in the last round
tomorrow morning uh
yes uh so that'll be a good uh mizzou
versus slew match-up yes
have you played her much before
uh i don't think i i have played her in
person to be honest probably it's going
to be our first one but
like she joined the university during
the pandemic so we played a couple of
online games but
not like classical one all right well
congratulations on the win today best of
luck in your game tomorrow thank you for
joining us
okay with that i believe we just have
one game remaining um which is going to
be this game between evan and ivan and
much like the alice lee game we have a
rook bishop and pawn against a rook and
a knight
uh in this case i was saying that this
one is going to be a little bit more
difficult for black to hold than in the
alice lee situation but should still be
a draw the big question here is going to
be
is white going to be able to force the
sacrifice of the knight for the pawn if
so we're going to get of course rook and
bishop versus rook which should be a
draw but you know even the grand masters
have a tendency to mess up that one um
so we shall see if uh if we get that far
in this game um to my eyes it looks like
uh ivan with the black pieces here is
going to be doing a pretty decent job of
uh
wait is this just concretely a draw i
think he's doing a pretty decent job of
slowing down this pawn
uh and it looks like he's finding some
some nice ideas here so so we just saw
knight c5 king b4 and now this knight
comes back to d3 with check again
and be careful about going up the board
here because i think that after knight
to c5
if you try b6 what's going on you can't
the bishop hangs okay
looks very very difficult to make any
progress so i like this construction
that black has found where he's
immobilizing the pawn by by interfering
with the rook's defense the bishop
i guess with white here you can
potentially try to swing the rook around
to the side
and it looks like this might actually
give give black some difficulties
um knight e5 was the choice instead
oh and i i just entirely missed this
idea so black is now threatening to take
on c6
and draw the game
maybe not i don't think you draw the
game here actually um this is losing
okay
so 95 still within the drawing margins
but uh getting tricky rook c1 was played
rather than rook c2
and
yeah this this one is it's just not easy
um
in fact it's so not easy that i'm almost
searching for a way to give up my knight
for this pawn um and it's not good if
you're searching
for
for the sacrifice into the
the rook and bishop versus rook end game
i do have the table base open here and
the table base says knight d3 is a draw
which sounds very confusing to me
because this would attack at night um
and king c5
what's
oh that's disgusting uh that's
disgusting
that is absolutely disgusting
um so knight d3 draws the game here if
rook d1 king c5 if you take the knight i
take on b5 and this is a draw that's
that's a good one that's
disgusting was the correct word for it
okay so we get rook f8 now and white
again is searching for a way to progress
this pawn up the board a single square
so what if i go bishop h1 uh the point
being saving my bishop from the threat
of capture
then it looks like it might be time
might be time just to do this just to
say enough is enough give me your pawn
let's play some chess
not uh not an envious task
vladimir i knew i was saying victor i
was thinking of mad vision oh my
goodness that's embarrassing um
sorry apologies to vladimir our rgm norm
group winner uh whoops
okay so what do we have going on here uh
not this
so in the game rook f8 king b6 so not
bishop h1 i wrote back to b8 check king
a7 okay so white isn't improving the
king here before before doing anything
um
and what to do here with black i guess
you move the rook out of the way right
back to f8 and yeah i mean this bishop
h1 idea seems like the try right you
want to go bishop h1
and
yeah i mean i'm not sure what else you
do with black here like it seems like
you you have to go for this this knight
d7 and just sacrifice
so white has done the the first step in
winning these end games which is force
the sacrifice of the knight for the pawn
and then the next step is potentially
harder against a good defense that step
is winning rookie bishop versus rook
which is a theoretical draw but you do
see you do see this end game get messed
up quite a bit uh even by players at at
the absolute highest level
so we'll see if white comes up with
bishop h1 or has some other idea can
also just be annoying here give a check
or something but
i'm not so sure that this check is going
to help you right king c7 i think your
best idea is to come back
um and then you know black will will
repeat
that being said getting some extra time
on the clock might not be a bad idea for
evan
let's see he was reaching he was
reaching for something
king b7 okay that move
seems strange i guess the idea is
actually this move uh rook d rook d one
check
and this move actually apparently is is
quite tricky
is quite tricky i'm told by the table
base here now this one is funny that uh
this move loses
but the loss is prevented by the 50 move
rule so
the more you know
that is actually kind of insane this
move loss also prevented by the 50 move
rule apparently it takes 122 ply to win
this position uh before you get to move
the b-pawn
um
so there's that for you end-game fiends
maybe we'll click through that line just
for fun
only two moves draw and this one very
human makes a lot of sense king's on the
best square stopping your king from
getting the c7 make the king move go
not knight d7
go rook f2 here i guess
and then i'm sort of confused this is
starting to look awkward starting to
look awkward the king is getting forced
away maybe now i'm going to come with
with something like bishop h1
but i i think yeah i think we're still
doing okay here
like here for example you you're even
getting checked again
work b1 neurostar b2
and
not much progress being made i think
okay
so rick f7 played so we're not going to
see knight g6 with the loss being
prevented by the 50 move roll
let's just let's just see what this is
yeah this this is the line this is
clearly the line
don't know why you would think this
wasn't the line
h7 king f6 yeah and only 50 more moves
to go before you get to move your b-pawn
only 50 more moves so the king gets
drawn all the way to the other side of
the board and then rook h1
rook c3 rook f1
all of these moves definitely
what the players had in mind and then of
course rook f5
so sorry not rick if i root f2 is better
c1
now rook f5 of course the stutter step
is important
yeah i'm done looking at that i am done
looking at that okay so rook f7 and then
rook f4 was black's choice so still
putting the work behind the pawn but now
the idea i think is that uh
he gains access to the c4 square which
might actually be very important
so rook d1 check now the king does still
have to move further away from the pawn
so sad uh and after bishop d5 check
thankfully all of our pieces are on dark
squares and we are allowed to just step
back to the d-file with the king
um black here taking a moment though
taking a moment
how could a loss be prevented by the 50
move roll with the pawn on the board
that's brutal
yeah the problem is um as soon as you
bring this pawn to b6 then it's on a
dark square and it might get attacked by
the knight um so i guess there's just 60
moves of setup before you you touch that
pawn
okay so king d6 on the board
and you can see the players there in the
lower right hand
and what to do with whites
white's doing a very good job of making
it tricky by the way i'm sort of
glossing over some of these things but
some of these moves are are not not so
obvious to draw like this one especially
after king b7 these these are the only
two moves to draw like rook f4 here you
might think is enough but it's no good
um yeah the wind prevented by by the 50
move roll though so
uh the point is though like you know the
the king starts to get pushed to the
other side of the board and that's when
it can can really get tricky
so that's the main thing that that black
is hoping to prevent here is getting the
king pushed all the way to the to the
wrong side of the board so king e7 of
course is the only move um it gets
played and now king c7 so you see this
idea now by by white he's cutting off
rook c4 check and he's just hoping to
drive the black king away so again it's
a very tricky moment here for black you
have to play one of these two moves
according to the table base in order to
draw and i think the idea is very simple
you just need to force the white king
off the c file allow your king access
back to this d file in the event of
something like rookie one um so there
are only a couple moves but i think
there are very human moves to find that
being said
in a position like this where you know
any move could be your last uh any move
here
uh
by black might might be the end of the
game so evan doing a very good job of
applying the pressure
yeah and vladimir says
his prediction is that white will win
which i i think i tend to agree with
here there's just too many too many ways
where you can go wrong and evan is doing
a very nice job of pushing this king
back like
very difficult to play here so rook f2
is played which i think is uh i mean
even better than then work f3 you just
general it's a little uncomfortable to
put your pieces on light squares
although you can argue you're gonna have
to come to a light square on on c2
um now what happens if we just go what
happens if we just go we give a check it
can be seven and
knight d7 i suppose is the simplest
so we can't just go you have to try a
little bit harder with white
can i explain the 50 move role oh
so in chess they have added this rule
where
in order to stop games that are drawn
but one side isn't really willing to
agree to a draw if 50 moves are made
without a piece being captured or a pawn
being moved so of course those are the
two ways that you know chess games are
sort of uh irreversibly advanced um then
the game is declared a draw um if i
declare to draw you you have to actually
you know write down the moves look at
them and say i would like to claim a
draw
um
so if you go 50 moves without moving
upon or capturing a piece the game is
drawn
bishop d5 played by white
so it looks like you know maybe white
has put this king on c7
and he's hoping to block this rook c2
check with bishop c6 and then he's
hoping to go with rookie one and again
force this king even further back so
very logical play by white here
everything he's doing is sort of with
this purpose of pushing that black king
further and further away
of course this is the lucena position
going to be easily winning for white so
no simplifications allowed
what move are we on now
let's check
b6 was not played
this is an important question
move 81 was when b5 was played we are on
move 93 so 12 moves have been played
just 12. rook c2 check played and now i
think bishop c6 is the idea yep bishop
c6 on the board
and just don't look at that that's not
true king e6 would lose
um so again the path is very very narrow
here for black he comes up with the only
move knight c4 not at all an easy move
to play um i guess he's realizing that
you just can't stop this pawn if if you
don't go knight c4 so knight c4 on the
board
but now white is getting what he wants
this king is all the way over to the f
file now very scary
a pawn move resets the 50 move role that
is correct
um and the reason being again it's it's
because it's irreversible right as soon
as you move upon it it can never go
backwards and you know if a pawn gets to
the end of the board um then it promotes
and then
[Music]
obviously by promoting it's no longer a
pawn so the game cannot continue into if
infinity
is the main idea
no infinite chess games allowed they all
have an end
there was an interesting question
actually
i'm not sure what the longest
theoretical chess game is
i guess it would be um
[Music]
i don't know how many pawn moves do you
have one two three four five
but then you have to calculate captures
because the pawns can't get to the end
of the board without capturing something
yeah i don't know i don't know what the
longest possible game is but
it's quite long but not infinite
so king f6 on the board and now white
has to decide how am i going to evict
this knight from a square where it's
defending b6 and that task is easier
said than done
as soon as you get the rook involved the
black king is going to step back get
closer to the action
maybe the answer is we we just keep
bullying this black king a little bit we
try to find ways to push it further and
further back and only once it's like way
on the other side of the board do we
start to focus on
on the knight here
um again though easier said than done
this knight is sort of ideally placed
it's stopping king d6 which is a move we
kind of need if we're going to push the
black king back another file
so looks like black has found a pretty
pretty nice setup here rookie 8 is a
good move it's very cagey just sort of
says all right it's it's your turn black
you play whatever you want so if i'm
black here i'm saying i pass
passing is is good
um 95 played instead that is not a pass
um so still stopping b6 thanks to the
pressure on this bishop on c6
um i would have been nervous about
playing 95 i would have been nervous
i think that's the first move that i
don't necessarily agree with from from
black although it is of course still
still well within the drawing margins
does rookie 5 work now rookie 5 almost
never works
i take your guy and we draw
uh yes so you don't practically in a
game you don't like count the moves one
by one and keep it running total you
look you see on move 81 you move to pawn
you can even just circle move 131 on
your score sheet so it's very very
visible to you like when uh when you're
going to need to move the guy
i'm so 95 king b7 knight back to c4 is
where we are at in the live position
and white
again
starts to think
so rookie four not going to be a good
move here knight d6
um
that one i can point out
yeah it it looks like black has done
enough to be able to sacrifice this
knight for for this pawn right he's
actually threatening knight d6 uh not
only with the idea of capturing the rook
but also with the idea of capturing the
pawn
so much so that i'm wondering if king c7
is going to get played again
is there a mask mandate for this
tournament no there is not
um there hasn't been a mass mandate in
st louis city for a few months now
um and we generally are following the
city guidelines
so we are going to see the dreaded rook
and bishop versus rook endgame and then
i am going to have a fun time
embarrassing myself with my lack of
knowledge about it but i will try i will
try to share
share my knowledge
whatever remains of it it's been quite a
while since i looked at it and even when
i looked at it i wasn't very thorough so
gonna be gonna be a rough one gonna be a
rough one
yeah so white really spending some time
here he's very reluctant to allow the
knight for pawn trade because
you know that then it it is of course
technically just a draw um
and having that knowledge can be a great
comfort for uh for black you know just
knowing whatever happens
technically it should be a draw
yep so king back to c7 is played um
stopping knight d6 so knight back to e5
um this is
twofold repetition which gets you
nothing
and up to white now to come up with a
better plan than king b7
minute 12 on the clock for evan
honestly i'm not sure how you press here
maybe you try king d6 maybe you try
coming this way
and after knight c4
you just sort of
you know you just go psycho on them just
be like yeah i'm bringing my king out
from in front of my pond where it had
shelter
because i want to mess with your night i
want to get your knight out of my face
and this is partially why i kind of
disagree with the decision to go with uh
to go with 95
because i i just didn't want to allow
this king in i i i think something like
a pass would have been uh
actually more testing um because then i
mean where are you going like what what
is what is the point of this move what
are you doing um rook d8 is white's
choice instead not wanting to go with uh
king to d6
now again i'm i want to put my knight
back i don't know why i put my knight on
e5 i want to back on c4 just just put it
back on c4 like what are we doing
knight a4 in that position is just
drawing
um knight a4 in what position
knight a5
um
yeah i mean i have to come back here i
guess and i've gone in a circle
okay you make a point you make a point i
did go in a circle
so i suppose king d5 would be the better
try
not allowing this this knight a5 idea
although actually not i could go king d5
here as well
if you check me
okay i can go here and then i don't know
if this is oh you have this and then
this okay
um
so king d5 here i guess is is the better
try
um but okay none of that actually
happened
and oh boy ill boy
oh boy
oh boy
it's over
technically a winning position after
this move rook to d5 so yeah i really
don't like this knight e5 idea you know
of course i have the benefit of a table
base um so i can just like look and and
see what's happening but i think knight
c4 was definitely
keeping the margins a lot wider for
black you can do a lot wrong as long as
your knight is on c4 b6 is not going to
win the game um and i think it was
worthwhile to force white to find some
way to kick this knight off of this very
nice square
with this move knight e5 um
you know suddenly b6 at some moment
might be very very dangerous and it
turns out that after king e7 or d5 um
the table base is is just saying that
this is completely winning so i'm going
to turn off the table base now and we're
going to see if we can find it you and
me as humans so knight c4 must be the
idea just coming back to defend uh
against the threat but now i imagine
rook c5
is kind of devastating um now b6 is a
threat if you take i take
and
what can you do
what can you do
i don't think you can do anything i
think this is dead
so knight c4 not going to be playable
but if you don't play knight c4
what do you do you go rookie 2 i just go
b6 knight c4 is too late now i push push
push
and that's going to be busto as well
okay so what did black come up with what
did black come up with
rook d5 king e6
now rook d6 check
okay so rook d6 by white so now of
course you you can't do this because
your bishop is attacked so rook d6 king
back to e7
um okay so this seems reasonable seems
like a reasonable try
it's a rook d-16 king e7 on the board
now how do we win
how do we win here can we push
can we just push
i think we can just push
pawn goes forward
i guess this is still tricky
if you queen
then
you lose yeah you just lose here
tough
so
you try this one
but then check and then queen
yep it's looking pretty brutal king e7b6
is on the board looks like evan has has
found the way
so yeah just leaving this knight on on
c4 i think was was the better try i
think this was what uh
black needed to do
so rather than 95 i i would have liked
to see just something like rick c1 and
then maybe you know white is going to
try this idea anyways
um of coming to uh c5 but i i think you
know maybe we can reposition our rook
here go rook b1 and it's not so easy to
to get my knight
uh to leave the action here let me let
me check
let me check am i drawing no i already
lost i already lost so i'm the [ __ ]
um nobody knows how to draw this game
um yeah nobody knows it's impossible
my loss was prevented by the 50 move
role though so i was doing okay
um now in the game though this is this
is just going to be over so
uh we saw rook d6 king e7 now b6 as we
said
black tried this move knight f7 um there
are more than one way there is more than
one way to win here this is one of them
uh king e6
now if you go b7
it's a draw
check
check
nice last ditch effort okay so white
does not fall for it goes rook all the
way to d1 says no thank you i do not
want to get forked
finds the trick
and yeah we're not going to make it to
to recommission versus rook thankfully
95 is played now we can repeat and go
here well not necessarily repeat but uh
now that the the knight is on a worst
square we can go b7 we sort of gained a
tempo there
yep king e7
and i fully expect b7 now no reason not
to
doesn't even take a second to think
about it he knows he knows it's b7
okay rook b2 on the board
and
now of course if you queen
i can take and take
so
one more moment of accuracy is going to
be needed here by white
uh i think rook d1 again is enough sort
of this mechanism we used to gain a
tempo last time also looks like it
should be good here
um of course something like rook c2 is
just never going to be enough you just
make a queen
you can take me i'll move out of the way
queens are worth more than knights and
white will win the game
um this is also not going to be good
enough
i think simplest might be to do this
or probably just checks checks are good
hard to lose when you give checks
um so should should just be directly
winning here yeah rook d1 played and
yeah if you don't play rook c2
then it's over but rook c2 as we said
not going to be enough
you will play rook h6
hey you played rock d1
um
and yeah vlad had it right here
black uh the path was just too narrow uh
evan did a fantastic job in my opinion
of of you know putting questions to
black that were not so easy to answer
yeah again i just really i really don't
think this 95 idea was was the way i
wanted to leave this knight on c4 uh
force white to to be the one that's
clever and creative
and coming up with a way to force me off
these squares
um this plan though does does seem sort
of very difficult right like let's say
king e7 rook d5 and now 95 is the only
move to to not lose otherwise rick c5 is
going to be good enough but that being
said knight a5 maybe not the hardest
move to find in that position either but
uh of course you know that that's just
one one threat you sidestepped and there
will be more to come
okay knight take c6 was played this of
course though is the lucena position
so we'll go we'll hide behind our pawn
and then we'll go rook d4 and win the
game
building a bridge
building a bridge
oh also sorry i played rook b2 in the
line i showed you're supposed to stay
over here force the king this way and
then you can do this
so that is why you have to do this if
you go rook b2
think um
this might also win
just do this and this and this
so
rk3 is the better try but still just rip
to d or to d4
why do they call it a bridge honestly i
have no idea i think it's a stupid name
i think it's a dumb name for it um i
don't know why they say building a
bridge
uh it doesn't make any sense it's more
like a shield you're like shielding your
king you know
building a shield
because like what what are you bridging
you're not bridging anything
there's no bridge
okay we're back to a1
and we are we are playing it out we are
playing out the lucena position good to
show the people at home
this is why you got to know your end
games kids at home
we are here live on the board now rook
b1 king sees king c6
and it looks like
the distance between these pieces is too
great you you will never be able to
block the checks of course if you run
behind your rook i come back here you
don't make any progress if you come back
this way to defend your pawn you don't
make any progress but
white can momentarily leave the defense
of the pawn
uh because of course the rook can't
attack the king in the pawn at the same
time and after check our rook is in time
to come save our life
maybe all of your pieces are on the same
file but you also don't like it um as
far as why it's called a bridge yeah
it's like i don't know because like a
bridge like a bridge is supposed to
connect things so you would think like
the bridge would connect the rook to the
pond but like no this is a wall it it
stops you
stops you from coming across
it's the opposite of a bridge
it's like if someone built a bridge and
then built a massive wall in the middle
of the bridge so no one could cross
and there's the handshake that is
resignation from ivan um and that is
going to be the end of our round today
so lots of fun games it's gonna be a
very fun round tomorrow for sure i'm
really looking forward to that josh
posthumour game versus aaron grabinski
in the im section that will determine
your im section winner uh once again
though story of the tournament so far
josh postuma has secured his im title we
crowned a new international master here
in st louis it's gonna be a lot of fun
um and anything else is just gonna be a
victory lap for him so congratulations
again to josh um and we will see you all
uh tomorrow for some some fun fun chess
in the final round
um
before we sign off why don't we take a
quick look at the results for the end of
today of course vladimir blues uh not
victor blues has secured victory in the
grand master section uh with his win
over josiah stearman today we saw a very
fun game in the sicilian there where
vlad got the best of josiah
after this f5 move and then some some
complicated tactics david brodsky also
uh has a nice win over joshua ruiz chris
and bilaji dogapatty have drawn their
game today evan just defeated ivan in
the battle of the two syllable
v-a-n names um and we saw kosciu uh
actually lose his game to to victor i
think that's a typo uh victor not
vladimir uh mad vision does defeat
kosher and then in the im section our
results today uh of course josh defeated
gabriella entova to win the
international master title uh the game
we saw with that nice win over ezra
alice drew against pedro uh we saw
jennifer yu taking out julian prolaco
and aaron grinsky won his game against
uh attorney leader matias meric
uh so with that i want to thank you all
very much for joining us here today
thank you to all the players who uh both
are just playing and especially the ones
who joined us here on the broadcast
always interesting to hear their
thoughts about their games uh after
after they finish uh be sure to join in
tomorrow at 2 p.m for our coverage over
the final round of the norm congress i'm
looking forward to it it's going to be a
lot of fun as always my name is caleb
denby i want to thank you all very much
for watching and we will see you guys
next time
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you